hi guys it's jay stokes uh you might
have seen me on outer banks if you
haven't
um i totally understand but if you
haven't watched it maybe go give it a
shot
but enough about what i've been in uh
let's get into what i've been binging
this is what are drew watching
[Music]
okay so i currently fell into the world
of lupine which is a netflix original
series which i think the second season
comes out soon
um i am a huge fan of sort of
mystery sort of plot twisting type of
shows and the characters were super
super nuanced
and um it was just shot really cool and
i fell in love with it it's a foreign
series so
turn on the subtitles and just
absolutely enjoyed it
and i genuinely genuinely am so excited
for uh season two to come out
so that's what i've been watching on the
tv front my favorite movie
ever contrary to belief
it's spy kids
[Music]
i uh i don't know i've watched it a
thousand times over again
uh i see a lot of juni and myself uh
daryl sabara who's a friend of mine
um was fantastic in that and then who
doesn't love antonio benderes
i mean the dude's a legend so
spy kids gotta go with spy kids all of
them never missed
well thanks for having me drew don't
forget to check me out on netflix's
outer banks
season two coming soon
you